all right guys
bang bang i've got ryan here thanks so
much for doing this man
yeah thanks and i'm really excited to be
here how you doing
i'm doing fantastic uh for those that
don't know you
let's just jump right into your
background you've done a bunch of
awesome stuff built some
pretty large companies uh maybe just
talk about like where'd you grow up and
kind of how did you get into the
business world yeah so i'm from the dc
metro i'm from uh maryland
and uh i i went to school
at northwestern uh in the midwest near
chicago
and then i went through the whole like
banking route did the
jp morgan lehman brothers worked at
deutsche bank during school
took a full-time job at deutsche out of
school uh did the investment banking
thing for a short while
and then i went to the the uh the carlow
group moved back to dc
worked in carlisle's u.s real estate
fund when it had about a three billion
dollar fund in uh
2006 and did a whole bunch of deals
there i was
learning a tremendous amount and then
while i was there i started doing real
estate deals
for my own account on the side and uh
and i was reading this newsletter called
biznow b-i-s-n-o-w which is
uh this father and son duo had uh
co-founded mark and alley biznow in dc
and i essentially cold approached them
and asked them if i could buy
a big chunk of the company and i ended
up doing that
and becoming ceo of that company and um
and spent seven and a half years scaling
that company from uh
which was you know newsletters an email
newsletter for every metro
market that we were in so we had 28
metro markets eventually
uh with a with a reporter in each one
kind of like imagine business insider
for commercial real estate
and we made a bunch of our our money was
really made on conferences and
advertising
and we scaled that to about 300
conferences a year
and about 7 million in profit a little
over 20 million top line and
sold it to a private equity firm in
2016.
i uh i replaced myself with um kind of
like my
my protege if you will who became ceo of
the company
and he's still there and uh and so
at the same time though um in 2008
elliot bisnow and i co-founded this
company with a with a few other
friends uh called summit or summit
series
um which is basically like this kind of
uh
community or gathering for all kinds of
people like
you know founders of companies
non-profit leaders activists
academics athletes uh you know anybody
who's a leader in some sort of space
and we would gather them for these like
really like immersive events that were
made up of
wellness and talks and art installations
kind of like burning man meets ted some
people
kind of refer to it and um yeah
eventually that became thousands of
people gathering at a time
uh you know they buy a ticket that's
like anywhere from you know four
thousand five thousand dollars
on average and we'd have all kinds of
you know amazing speakers and
personalities there we've got
bezos and branson and shonda rhimes and
jessica alba and
reed hastings from netflix ted turner
brene brown al gore
now all kinds of you know really
interesting people who would come and uh
you know inspire the community and and
many of them were part of the community
and then in 2012 we bought a 10 000 acre
ski resort
it's actually the largest ski resort by
by acreage in the u.s
in utah a ski resort called powder
mountain
which is actually where i'm at right now
uh it's absolutely
beautiful here right now and uh we it's
about a seven lift
uh you know four restaurant 000 acre ski
resort and we
um we've been essentially becoming
developers of the resort so
we're we're building roads we're
building utilities we're building uh
lodges
and hosting our events here and building
this community here
like it's a it's still you know open to
the public but there's also an element
to the community that's like a
membership
uh as well and so we've sold about 150
million dollars worth of real estate
here
since 2012 um and it's been kind of an
interesting way to think about
extending a media brand or a community
brand into a real estate project
um and uh we started a 30 million dollar
venture fund at one point called summon
action
which invests in startups and uh started
a non-profit called the summit institute
um which is a 501c3 and yeah
and i still do real estate investing and
my main focus for these days actually is
trying to buy small
companies and we're we're actually a
friend of mine
helping him close on on the company next
week so that's been kind of a crazy
adventure
so you um not only one have built uh
multiple companies
uh you've also done everything from
media to software to real estate to kind
of community building and you've just
got a lot of
what i'll call kind of practical
experience and
expertise so throughout this
conversation i think we'll kind of talk
through a lot of just like
the lessons you've learned from the
operator seat
but maybe talk a little bit let's go
back to biz now and talk a little bit
about like tactically
um you know once you bought the business
what was kind of the state of the
business and what did you do to actually
grow it to a 20 plus million dollar
uh top line seven million dollars in
profit what were those steps that you
took and why did you do that
yeah so you know the idea was to build
like a mini conglomerate of sorts like i
i was looking for
a cash flow positive company and then i
would take the cash flow and invest in
real estate that was my original
thesis well i didn't i underestimated
how busy i would become
running biz now and so i frankly ended
up you know just becoming like kind of
more of a passive real estate investor
than doing as many deals as i thought i
would on my own
but um but the way that you know we
scaled that was
was by market so you know i'd go to new
york and crash couches with friends and
hire our first writer and then i would
make
the first sales myself selling
advertising um and get it up to break
even and
you know one thing that we would do is
whenever i'd go to a new market i would
go to all of the
the top firms in the space and say look
we're only going to have one law firm on
all of our advertising for a year
and we're only going to have one
accounting firm and one you know lender
and i'm talking to five of you and one
of you is going to get it and i'm going
to give you a big discount
and i'm going to give you all the ad
inventory for a year and you're in your
exclusive category
and that really worked well like i could
get you know the first
five six key stakeholders and then that
would basically pay for the writer and
pay for me to hire a sales person
i would pay for some of our overhead for
a year and
i just basically did that market by
market and the thing i thought was kind
of cool about that is we
we never took any outside capital so we
ended up owning a lot more of the
company than you know your typical
kind of growth company or startup um
through this kind of like profitable
sales
method and then you know once we got you
know maybe
i don't know five to ten thousand
subscribers in a market we would start
producing our own conferences
and the conferences would bring in
ticket sales through our website
and our sales team that was selling the
ads would sell the sponsorships to it
and we would do an event pretty much
every month in every market and
eventually even
as much as like three events per month
per market
and we became uh you know obsessed with
data
you know how can we have the most data
on our audience so that we could deliver
an event
on hotel development in brooklyn and
have 400 people show up
when like you know the competitors at
best could have maybe
200 people show up for a hotel
development event for like the tri-state
area of new york
like we could get super niche and really
deliver like a really specific audience
for a specific
um event like like that example and then
you know the next week we might do an
event on
you know midtown office uh you know real
estate in midtown manhattan so
like really really super niche uh was
kind of uh you know like
our belief is that there was riches and
niches and we could deliver like this
really specific audience
um so that was like part of the
methodology
uh i'd say one other thing about it too
is i think we learned pretty early on
that
if you're gonna produce 300 events a
year publish 28 newsletters
every single day five to six days a week
it's all about systems and making it
replicable which initially we were
terrible at
initially you know we would try to have
like one smart person like me kind of
just do
everything like you know i'd i'd get the
speakers i'd figure out the contract
with the hotel
i'd show up and you know the morning and
get all the chairs arranged
you know i'd even write some other copy
i'd edit some of the copy
and um and initially that was the model
i kept trying to find like replicas of
like our founders and people like myself
uh who could do kind of everything and
what i learned is that you know most
people are just like
you know they're not gonna necessarily
be that dynamic and uh and
maybe it's that they don't have enough
equity i don't know but
it was hard to get you know these people
so i ended up
studying this company um called iir
had that had hundreds of conferences and
figured out oh wow they break it down
into an assembly line
and so we basically had a programming
department that gets all the speakers
a production department that handles all
the coordinating and all the contracting
and details
and shows up and actually executes on
the event uh a marketing department that
does all the
constant email marketing i mean every
day we're sending marketing about you
know hey check out the speaker you
should sign up
you know card abandonment all the
e-commerce stuff and then the fourth
department was
sales and then those four departments
are supported by hr
technology and accounting
and um and we invested really heavily
too in like our crm
and so just making this whole thing like
this assembly line was
was really critical and talk a little
bit about
um the systemization so you just
described kind of the buckets but
maybe walk through there's a lot of
people who run a business
and uh human capital is the solution to
every problem right they just throw
bodies at something uh and for many
people especially kind of small business
owners they throw themselves at the
problem
you were able to kind of at different
points in that business
uh build systems so that you didn't have
to write every newsletter
do every sale kind of all that stuff but
then also eventually on the transition
when you sold the business you were able
to step away from the business and not
have to kind of continue running it
so talk a little bit just about like how
did you design the systems and then what
were the steps it actually took to
implementing them
yeah so i basically tried to take
everything that seemed
hard to uh formulate and turn it into a
formula
so like for the writing we turned we
created this like manual
for like these are all the do's and
don'ts kind of like a design guideline
you know we we don't we speak in the
first person we you know we write
headlines that look like this
uh we write this many words typically we
our photos should never look like this
but they should look like this
and um it definitely was far from
perfect it's not like i just handed this
manual and people just instantly could
write it like this but
um but over time we managed to train
people and then you know put in place a
certain amount of management and culture
that people could replicate the writing
and the same thing on the speaking like
we're like you know we want we need
a certain percentage of the speakers to
look like this in a certain percentage
like this
and you know when we set up chairs in a
ballroom we never want them just to all
be forward we want them to be curved or
we want to be theater of the round
so we basically break as many things
down into formulas even though
i was really obsessed with like the
sales processes because matt it was a
huge difference between a good
salesperson and a mediocre one
and uh like a lot of them don't schedule
the next meeting in the meeting
they just want to email the proposal
instead of present the proposal because
they're kind of you know scared to talk
about
price and all these kinds of things that
make a huge difference in conversion
and so we had to basically build
training programs
and and also i found that you know
people forget like 80
of what they learn in the training
program when they join so you basically
need to have like a continuing education
where you're just
constantly every week getting people
back together and teaching them and
going into the field
and then another thing i i think we we
learned eventually was
hiring multiples of people at a time and
hiring full-time recruiters
if you have a lot of great talent coming
into the company
you can put pressure on the people that
are in the company that like that
you know that they're replaceable and
that there's great talent coming up the
pike and they've to keep improving and
honing their skills
um and also it was a cool thing because
then they would teach the people who are
coming in and
people learn a lot through teaching and
so we built this whole kind of like
apprenticeship program
you know each department was constantly
bringing in new talent
and training them and we had two to
three full-time recruiters we're just
constantly hiring people um and the one
other thing i learned was
whenever i do something new myself as a
ceo i should never be doing it alone i
need to have like
at least two to three people learning it
with me as apprentices
and you know one of those people is
going to end up being outstanding one
will be kind of so-so and one will
probably have to
let go within a year and so i i used to
like hire one person at a time i started
trying to hire at least three at a time
for any role um
especially when you're growing you know
if all three of them are amazing great
you'll find
you know you'll find a place for them so
i think some of those things were key
and
yeah that investing in getting office
spreadsheets
and into a crm was a huge thing like we
we took we not only put our
um our sales in the crm we put all of
our speakers
and a lot of the people we wrote about
and all the information about them we
were constantly adding to this this like
central database and so it got the job
got easier and easier like if you're
trying to get a great speaker for like a
podcast
we could just click a button and say
okay who do we know that's real estate
that's hotel that's in los angeles
for this event and we could just click a
couple of buttons and get an email out
to them
um and so that made it a lot easier as
we got as we get scaled
yeah and then these training programs i
think uh probably if you ask most
entrepreneurs what are they really bad
at
it's like onboarding training and that
continued education
uh you spent um what seems almost like
an inordinate amount of time money
resources mental energy
on these uh kind of supporting actions
of the system so you got to design the
system you got to implement the system
and then like it's almost like garbage
in garbage out type
uh you know scenario so talk a little
bit about those training programs that
you set up what were you guys
optimizing for and kind of how did those
operate
so every time we hired a new a new
employee we'd say
here's the existing manual tear this
thing up and and make it better
because you're good because in your
first 90 days you're going to learn the
most and you're going to see a lot of
things that we don't even
remember or see anymore and so like
every week you owe
us a cert you know a certain amount of
track changes and updates to this manual
and it's great because new people are
are like i said they're like they have
fresh eyes and so they're
so we we were constantly refining we had
a manual for editorial we had one for
you know uh producing the event one for
contracting the you know the hotels
whatever it was
and then and then when people would join
we'd put them into like a four to six
week program where we
where we'd have someone in that
department and sometimes even
myself for part of the time or my co go
in and
actually train them and then we bring
them into the field and actually
we learned that just telling people
things doesn't really work they have to
do it themselves and so
you know the first weeks we'd get them
to actually do a lot of this stuff
and uh and then you know help and be
corrective and then eventually once they
got
good you know it was all about getting
out of their way and like removing
um and just throwing you know resources
at them here's more talent that we'll
hire for you here's more money that will
throw out your ideas
um because that was that was and that
was challenging and i think
also i learned that sometimes you have
to allow like a department to do 70
as well as you might do yourself as the
founder like there were definitely tons
of times where i'm like man i think
had i shown up at this event i would
have done the chairs this way i would
have gotten this speaker
oh i would have made this sale you know
seven thousand instead of five thousand
and um i kind of had to let go of that
in order for us to grow
and um but that was challenging
initially because i i definitely was
like you know always wanted to like fix
and optimize everything
and then other times people would weigh
exceed my you know they'd make like
mistakes initially
and then they would learn and then they
would get way better than i could ever
be so
um i don't know i that it perfectly
answers the question but
you know those are some of my
observations yeah and then
both of the businesses that you built um
you did so with
no outside funding um talk a little bit
i know you've got a whole bunch of
thoughts on
uh kind of venture capital versus
bootstrapping and maybe some of the
fallacies that people fall victim to
there
um you kind of take us down that path
however you want to but but just really
comparing the venture route to
uh to one that doesn't involve outside
capital
yeah i mean i've been kind of like an
evangelist recently of trying to
persuade more and more people that
they don't need to pursue venture i just
you know having worked
at summit like like you i think we've
both seen so many entrepreneurs in the
venture space and
and i just see a lot of them suffer from
a tremendous amount of anxiety because
they've got to keep hitting these growth
numbers
because their only opportunity to make
any real money besides their salary
is to sell the company generally and it
usually takes like seven to twelve years
to get to the place where they actually
sell
uh when i first went into it i thought
it was like a five year thing but it's
it's longer
and then you know if they're losing
money which they often are because
they're so focused on growth they're
only the only place they can exit to
is a strategic because they are going
public right they
they can't sell to a private equity firm
typically because they want profitable
companies
uh they're not going to do a management
buyer they can't you know they can't
borrow debt against their companies it's
not profitable typically
and so and most of them aren't big
enough to go public
and um and so and strategics are kind of
like
they're they kind of come and go there
might only be three or four of them and
they're kind of temperamental
um it depends on their mood and their
goals of that year
so i'm a huge fan of like i think i
think a lot of businesses could start
off without venture
and and so like my example for for you
know one example is
pre-sales you can pre-sell sell your
some sort of product so if you're like a
subscription software product go to your
customers
and say look i'm gonna give the first
you know 50 customers
um a lifetime membership where you know
give us like you know three years of
what this product costs and you'll get
it for
life uh if you're like a membership you
can do something similar
um you know i just spoke to like a
manufacturing company like an amazon fba
sort of company
and they had a really cool approach they
went to um
some companies that would want to buy
their product in a b2b sale and said
we'll give you exclusivity for your
region so that your competition doesn't
have our products it was like a
packaging product
and um and you got to give it you're
going to pay us an exclusivity fee
and then they use that fee to pay for
the tooling and the initial the initial
prototyping of the product
and got them off the ground without any
outside capital and
you know one thing i love about this is
if you sell a company for
you know 50 million without venture like
that's like the equivalent of selling
your company for like
two three four hundred million with
venture capital typically
and so you don't have to scale nearly as
large and so you don't have to focus on
as much growth and along the way if you
want you can take distributions if
you're profitable and so you know there
were many years where we were making
really nice money like living off of
distributions and salary
and still reinvesting millions of
dollars into the business and growing it
and so i just found that we had a lot
less stress
in like years four five and six that a
lot of my
my friends who are you know have 200
employees they're losing 10 million a
year bringing in 30 million and they're
they're just hoping and praying that
like salesforce requires them or you
know whatever
you know shopify buys them or whatever
it might be so
yeah and i one other thing i'll say
about that is i think um
part of that comes down to the ideas
that you choose the business ideas if
you're going to get started
for every market that you're interested
in that you're excited about maybe
you're excited about crypto or excited
about you know whatever it is
there's a continuum of like capital
intensive businesses to capital like
businesses
and i would suggest for many people they
start capital light
and then you know over time invest the
profits from that capital light business
maybe it's a consulting business or a
service business initially
and as you're getting that cash flow
invest it into your product business
and your more capital intensive business
you know maybe you have to build a piece
of software for two years before you can
release it
but you start with having an agency that
serves the same clients your software is
going to serve
and so you basically you essentially are
able to
you know finance your business through
this initial business model
so yeah that's the kind of thinking that
i'd love to spread more out
and i think that as you do this like
project selection or market selection
uh it's a huge determinant of whether
you're going to be successful or not and
your point about
um based on what market you choose can
determine a lot about do you need tons
of capital or can you kind of bootstrap
and
drive some cash flow but one of the
things that you've done over and over
again is
uh you take these like a highly
ambitious kind of pie in the sky really
dreams right or
goals and you're always able to pull it
back to
very rational plans and very kind of
execution driven plans
how do you think about uh being able to
kind of context switch right so hey i
want to go after this big market here's
kind of the
end goal or where i see this going but
then being able to kind of you know come
back down to reality if you will
and say okay here are the 10 things we
need to do in the next three months in
order to kind of keep going down
the road that we're going down in order
to get to that goal
yeah so like one thing is we i like the
idea of not worrying too much
about a massive total adjustable market
instead thinking about a minimum viable
market just initially at least
so like you know maybe i want to build
um
you know take the real estate example of
biz now like maybe we want to build the
largest commercial real estate
you know news and media business but
and maybe we even want to eventually get
into software and do other things or buy
a ski resort but initially i just
focused on
you know can i build a following and a
profitable business in washington dc
and get everybody who cares about real
estate in that one market to know who we
are and buy our product
and then launch it to new york and we
did the same thing with summit we
started with 19
founders and then eventually we got you
know then it was 85 and then 140
and you know our last event was over 3
000 people
and we took the you know the cash flow
from that and the know-how and the iep
and the community that we built from
that and then we formed another joint
venture
and a separate llc and this this is one
that i love to think about is
how do you structure separate separate
llcs so that you can
if you don't want to dilute your initial
company you can still do
ambitious new projects so like you know
maybe you get like the pop brand going
and you've got this you know profitable
engine
and you decide like you know you want to
build i don't know the pop hotel chain
and uh that appeals to all the kinds of
people who you know are into the pomp
brand
well you could start another joint
venture with a you know
a private equity firm perhaps that funds
it and maybe a hotel development company
and license your brand to that other
entity
and control your brand through the
license
get royalties for that and maybe you
even uh you know raise money for the
venture and take a significant piece
if the venture does well in an upside in
the form of carried interest or promote
and so i think thinking about structure
is super important um and at the same
time thinking about you know how do you
initially get some cash flow going in
and a brand coming in and
how do you hire those first five
employees and uh
one other thing i'll say is um i was
talking to an entrepreneur last week and
he was gonna start like a new
kind of like a community for uh techies
and he was gonna raise a million bucks
and i asked him like well
you know how do you know how to price
this he's going to charge like 300 bucks
for this product
and he was like oh you know it seems
like uh the competition is like you know
this much and so
i'm going to charge you know 300 bucks
to come in a little cheaper
and i was helping him like i think
everyone should build their budget first
it doesn't really take a whole lot a lot
of time like if you just take a few bids
on everything and you look at what like
you know your first
employees are gonna cost what the
product's gonna cost and then
price it with margin above that budget i
think a lot of like early entrepreneurs
they just gotta throw out a random price
they don't really like back i like to
back into my price
so that i know instantly that if i sell
one unit it's a profitable unit
and if i'm if i'm gonna sell it at a
loss then it's it's on purpose
it's not like you know by accident um
so yeah i don't know those are a few
thoughts on that
and so one of the things that you've
talked about in the past uh and i think
just really nails at home is like what's
the purpose of all this
right so the systems the uh operational
efficiency and excellence the
um bootstrapping versus uh venture
like it's this idea that you've talked
about where entrepreneurship
gives you the freedom and it can
alleviate a lot of the like financial
anxiety
um or financial issues talk just like
from a high level somebody who's saying
i may want to go do this
but like what's the purpose right or how
should i think about it i think you've
got a very kind of
sober view of um you know
this is what this allows people to do
and some people want to optimize for
that some people don't but maybe just
describe that a little bit
yeah so for me i i was you know
like a lot of people not super happy
working in banking and private equity
was you know working these crazy hours
and um
and was you know found it just not not
as rewarding as i was hoping you know
like i was on this track that it was
super appealing
that everyone wanted to get into in
college and i finally arrived at
carlisle you know it's one of the top e
firms
and i wasn't really i really wasn't that
satisfied i didn't see my family a lot i
couldn't pursue my hobbies anymore um
and
and so and i wasn't really working on
something that i was super passionate
about and so
i went down this entrepreneurial route
and what i discovered is that being an
entrepreneur can also be super stressful
and cause a ton of
anxiety you know you're you're trying to
keep up with growth and you're
multitasking and you're managing all
these people all of a sudden and so
i've and now looking back i've been you
know i like this idea of like holistic
entrepreneurship where
you know you really you're trying to
solve um
for your well-being and you're trying to
solve for
you know real wealth which to me is not
just about getting
rich you know financially it's also
about gaining freedom the
you know the freedom to self-express the
freedom to set your hours the freedom to
pursue
you know your interests and have time
for family and friends as well as your
business and your team
the freedom to work with people that you
love working with um
and so i think entrepreneurship is this
amazing vehicle
for uh being able to achieve that sort
of freedom
and i think you know but the key is to
avoid some of the traps
of you know growth at all costs uh you
know growth can be
like a cancer and it can kind of like
eat you so i think if you can
um structure things the way some of the
ways i was discussing
you can have this like really fun and
really enjoyable
outcome as you go um and just like take
it like in small little steps
bit by bit uh and gain a tremendous
amount of freedom and also solve
financial
anxiety i know i i suffer and still do
but you know especially early on
uh from a lot of like you know insecure
financial insecurity like am i going to
have enough to you know pay the bills as
i'm building this business
can i take care of my you know my family
that i hope to have in you know the
future
and you know retire and all these you
know questions that you know plagued all
of us
and so i was very focused on like trying
to mitigate risk as i grew the business
and try to ensure that
we would have enough cash to you know
weather storms and things of that nature
and so you've obviously spent uh the
last number of years building businesses
and done it at a very kind of high
degree of success
you've been able to build really
interesting communities that are not
only full of
successful powerful interesting people
but also
um can be quite profitable uh but
at kind of the heart you started out
wanting to do real estate investing
and so talk a little bit about how you
think about uh
investor versus operator today and
uh you kind of merge them it seems like
or there's like now a little more of a
gray area because
uh you literally own powder mountain and
you guys are selling real estate there
but just talk a little bit about kind of
capital allocator versus operator
yeah i think there's a tremendous amount
of power and being able to if you really
understand
both and i i think a lot of startup
people don't really understand private
equity
a lot of private equity people don't
really understand startups and if you
understand
if you consider the intersection of
those two things then
you can do some really powerful things
so you know
like an example i give is um i i'm
really fascinated by barry stern like to
create a star wars capital and start a
property group and
you know hotels like the st regis and
hyatt and the one hotel and
you know like just as an example you
know he'll buy
um like he bought the bacharach crystal
company have you heard of this company
no what is that so like there's this
company has been around forever
they make these like you know crystal
chandeliers and i think they make like
you know silverware that's beautiful and
so he buys this company underneath his
private equity firm
he takes the brand and he uh
builds a hotel brand using the bachrod
name
so buying the crystal company in itself
was a good buy like he bought it at a
decent valuation
and then if you could grow that brand
over time you know as more and more
consumers and places like china
you know are becoming middle and upper
class bakarat's going to grow
but at the same time he took that brand
and did something new with it so
he launches a new uh vertical that's a
hotel brand
and with his uh private equity fund
he funds the development of a new hotel
in midtown manhattan
with condo and hotel and he joint
ventures with a developer so he puts up
the capital for it from the fund
he licenses the brand from his bacharach
crystal company that
the fund owns and he gets a developer
who really is an expert in building you
know skyscrapers to actually build the
hotel
and so he's playing in like all parts
you know he's making money on royalties
he's making money from
at baccarat for through the brand and
the license he's making money for the
private equity fund on both the
bacharach company and the new hotel
development
he's got a partner who's handling the
day-to-day of building that hotel so
he's leveraging his human capital so to
speak
instead of having to build all that
internally and um and so he's kind of
playing in all the different components
of this and so he's able to do that
because he really understands like
everything from
from brand and design and operation to
also understanding
capital markets and structuring and i
think that
more and more people should learn how to
do this you know i think virgin's
another great example of being able to
do that and so
i've been trying to apply things i
learned at carlisle and things i've
learned as an operator
and trying to sit at the intersection of
these things so you know summit is a
brand and has events
and powder mountains a joint venture we
can you know leverage that brand to be a
developer
and we can use our hospitality expertise
to improve the management of
the mountain and make that you know a
better feel when you show up at a
restaurant for example
and um and then the brand of the
mountain
strengthens the brand of the summit
community and the summit events because
more people hear about the mountain
more people want to come to the events
more people hear about the events more
people want to buy a piece of real
estate in the mountain
or just come out and ski and so you're
you're kind of starting to leverage all
these different things
so i think that's a really there's
interesting ways to approach like you
know
building businesses in this way yeah
it's really interesting
uh when you start to think about the
importance of iep
um and using ip as an asset or a
resource just as much as capital
human labor or anything else right
yeah i mean i like what you said in
another show about bar stool
and how you know they should have bought
pen gaming you know potentially that
i i i think it's smart you know like
like like like you were saying you know
they could use their brand they've got
this huge following
and uh you know they could they could
launch a new app for
sports betting you know the bar stool
app with the infrastructure of a
gambling organization
and uh and leverage that brand to make
money in a whole new way
in addition to having their you know all
their their multimedia platforms
so i think a lot of people could do this
like even on a small scale
um you know like i spoke to a guy
recently who
was uh manufacturing pickleball rackets
and selling them on amazon
and nice profitable company you know
doing a half a million of profit
um and you know but it was it's
competitive on amazon so he was you know
he was growing but it's it's hard to
grow there's more and more competition
every day
but one thing he could do is launch you
know a league for example
and you know he's got a following people
love the brand of his racket
so he could he's got an email list so he
could announce them hey listen we're now
going to do this thing where it's you
know 50 bucks a month
and we're gonna if you you know we're
going to meet once a week and we're
going to have a tournament
and he can start to expand into like a
totally different vertical
and uh you know i especially like that
vertical because it's kind of capital
light
so it wouldn't need a lot of money to
launch it you could experiment and shut
it down in six months if it doesn't work
and so yeah again like leveraging your
brand and your operational expertise to
play and you could
you know he could also do that in a
separate llc he could join venture
with another entrepreneur like let's say
he doesn't have the time to build
and manage a new company well another
way to go about it is he joined ventures
with someone else
and they launch that and they run and
they've got skin in the game
and you know they panel royalty or you
they you know they give them 30
of the equity in the business um you
know i think there's a lot of different
ways to skim the cap
absolutely and so i guess as part of
this um
you now are looking at uh kind of going
out
and finding brands to acquire and scale
and
grow uh maybe before we get to the types
of things you're looking for
i know you and i have talked about a
couple of different types of businesses
and what you could do with them so we'll
play a game of what i'll call
hypothetical
private equity um to to kind of go
through
uh let's start first with uh tony
robbins and
his business what uh what would you do
and kind of
how do you think that business could be
improved
yeah so i love tony robbins business and
i went to my first tony robbins event
last year
super impressive uh incredible business
huge following
you know die hard fans and you know it's
largely monetized through conferences
or seminars you know where thousands and
thousands of people gather
for five days and they learn a
tremendous amount and
you know but one thing i noticed is they
they just kind of go home and
and they listen to free stuff that he
puts out and you know he provides
coaching and some other services and
and uh and and by the way i you know he
runs an amazing business
uh but i think there's ways that you
could take that and extend it right so
one thing is would be to build a monthly
forum uh you know there's ypo
and vistage and other companies there's
a company called chief now in new york
that's super successful
where you get people together in groups
of ten they meet once a month some it's
actually producing this now
uh something like this called junto and
you meet once a month and you're
basically a support group for one
another to help each other achieve your
goals both personally and professionally
in the case of tony robbins maybe even
spiritually and i think that could be a
super sticky product and
his his audience would you know pay at
least five grand a year for a product
like that
you know ypo costs 10 to 20 grand and i
mean these are like 30 percent
you know ebitda margin businesses uh for
kind of the vistage does
over 100 million dollars in profit sold
to private equity so
i you know that's like one extension
that he could sell as people are leaving
the the seminar
you know from there you know i i've just
been one thing i've been really
interested in just
if you learn like 20 different
monetization tactics
then you can kind of come up with
infinite permutations of things you
could do if you bought or
started a company and so you know
another thing you can do is build a lead
gen business where
he builds the best seo you know related
content on all things mental health
he's already kind of famous for that he
already has a lot of traffic to his
website
so he can build you know a huge amount
of media on his site that covers every
topic about mental well-being
and then people end up on those pages
and he could be an affiliate marketer
where he's driving traffic to you know
different products
around that space and and taking you
know a cut through lead gym
um he could build a premium subscription
newsletter like like you've done of
course
uh and an online community kind of like
trends by the hustle where you know
people meet in a private facebook forum
as part of that premium subscription um
and share tips and you know share
notes on how are they getting you know
managing life um
i also think a cool way to extend his
brand would be
you know kind of like i was saying he
could build a private equity firm
and buy other companies in the wellness
space and then leverage his huge
following
to promote those companies he's also got
just an amazing
set of operators in his business that
could drop into those companies and help
improve operations
costs whatever it need be you know i
thought one cool thing i don't know if
many people know this
did you know jimmy buffett has a real
estate you know division as well
i did not like margaritaville buffett's
company
not only does it you know have like a
radio station i think xm sirius and
of course you know his concerts but he
started a senior a senior living
development brand
where if you want to live the margarita
style lifestyle as a retiree
like you know you know tons of people
would love to live that lifestyle
you can move down to florida and live in
one of his senior developments
and uh and live in this like really cool
culture so
i think you know tony robbins has this
huge following
especially among baby boomers who you
know have a lot of disposable income and
they
they want to you know visit wellness
resorts and retreats and
you know maybe go to meditation centers
around the world so i think you could
build a
uh kind of a hospitality brand um as
well so
yeah i mean i could go on and on with
ideas for his company but i think once
you have a following like that and
expertise
there's a lot you can do and it feels
like really what you're talking about
here
is uh that following has bought into uh
a way of thinking a way of life right
and they feel
uh part of their identity is attached to
that and when you reach that point
uh you can apply in so many different
ways from a business perspective right
yeah i think someone smarter than me
said focus on psychographic instead of
demographic
and uh we've certainly seen that with
summit like we have people who
are kind of like gray-haired millennials
if you will who are
you know 65 years old but
they you know when summit started was
all people under 30.
and now there's you know all these
incredible people who are
you know in their 60s 70s even who
are going to kind of share the ethos and
they share the
energy of wanting to create things and
have an impact on the world and
you know other things that kind of
appeal to the summit kind of uh
psychology and so yeah i think if you
can focus on the psychographic of your
audience
there's a lot that you can do with that
and you can kind of lean
have more heavily into that
psychographic uh and get a lot more
you know out of it out of your following
for sure
uh another business uh that you've
talked about is uh vaynermedia which is
um
you know different but but has some of
the same elements as a tony robbins type
business
what are what are the thoughts around
something like a vayner media or media
agency
so you know agencies are traditionally
kind of like they're challenging
businesses they're lower multiple
businesses
they only grow through adding adding
employees typically
you know because every time they get a
new customer they need more bodies to
support the customer
and so but it's a great business for
bringing in cash flow
it's a great business for getting out
your name and they can scale very
quickly
and and they only you know you don't
have to like scale them ahead of your
your your profitability you can grow
them as you get more clients
but if you want to transition an agency
into a higher multiple
business there's one you could come out
with a product
and so like you know vayner could
develop like a piece of software for
social media maybe they should have been
the next you know they should have been
hootsuite
uh you know so they could i'm sure still
come out with a great software product
and
just to leverage their huge brand and
following um
but another thing they could do too is
launch a venture fund
and um you know i think hawke media did
this in l.a eric huberman's company
where you know in addition to having
this this agency
you know they have access to so much
deal flow they're seeing so many
problems that need to be solved
and they're helping so many startups and
so you could launch a venture fund with
a group of
you know frankly with a lot of your
customers could be your investors and
then you could use that to make
bets on the companies that you're
servicing and and use this
kind of unique perspective that you have
and then that just makes your
clients even more kind of sticky uh
because you know
you've also become their investor i also
think you can make a private equity fund
like
say you're an seo agency and you you
help companies optimize
how they show up on google well you have
so much insight into
you know certain verticals and how to
get the best seo for those those sites
you might as well buy those sites and
roll them up and
if you roll them up and take them public
i mean you could even take advantage of
the public markets right now where
multiples
for public companies are higher than
private typically
and uh you know with facts and
everything so you could you could have
an amazing outcome
you know rolling up uh you know blog
sites let's say if you're an seo
specialist
or if you're an e-commerce agency you
could do this where you're rolling up
you know ecom companies
um like thrash is doing um and then
actually provide them
this this service you know vista
partners is a good example like they're
this
amazing private equity fund and one of
their they buy you know um
enterprise software companies but at the
holding company they have a consultancy
and they drop that consultancy into the
companies they buy and improve all their
operations
with their own consistency they kind of
just like formula that they know
is going to work before they buy the
company and so i think
boehner is super well positioned to do
that and um they have so much expertise
internally that you know
most what company has a thousand people
internally like vayner that's got all
these
experts that they could deploy and
leverage so
yeah i think and then i also love events
obviously in a post covered world
i think vayner could create a huge
social media agency
i i love how salesforce launched
dreamforce i i used to be so jealous of
i'd go to dreamforce and be like you're
kidding me this software company is a
more successful events company than my
company and i'm a full-time events
company like
they've got you know i forgot what it is
you have 50 000 people buying tickets
and
you know huge companies buying booths
and you know that
it's crazy that a software company owns
that and so
i think that's uh you know it's huge
business the trade show business is a
very high multiple business
and um i think vayner could crash it in
building like a social media
trade channel yeah and talk a little bit
about
uh how this changes for uh non-product
companies
like creating products or buying product
companies and then
using them to kind of scale so i think
one of the disconnects is like oh if
you're in the agency business like then
most people think you just have to stay
in software
right they don't understand um no
actually
and gary's kind of done this a little
bit i think in terms of he's bought some
companies right and then try to use the
expertise they have online to scale it
we see
um guys like ty luke as i was i recently
listened to him sampard
and sean purry uh talk through um
basically he's just buying up pier 1
import stress bar and whatever and he's
like hey i'm better at the internet than
most people and so i can mark
the stuff on the internet like how do
you think about that
meshing or intersection of these
software businesses and skill sets with
those physical products
yeah i mean i'm really really excited to
see if the tai lopez model
how that ends up playing out but um
i think you like if you have if you have
like a media brand you've got a big
following i think like you said
about barstool you know you can go buy
or i think you also said about joe rogan
like you know joe rogan could go buy a
physical product that's sold on on
amazon sold through shopify and
ecommerce
and leverages his you know not only his
his following but he's like you know
he's got this kind of
like sticky die hard psychology around
what he's built and he could leverage
that
to um to promote a brand i think someone
who does this really really well
is golden hippo uh craig clemens company
they kind of fly under the radar but
they
are this kind of like holding company
that is behind a lot of
direct-to-consumer brands
and their methodology is they find a
guru kind of an
expert who's known in a space you know
usually like a doctor
and they find some famous doctor you
know the the leading cardiologist who's
like you know
you know worked on you know bill clinton
and you know everyone kind of knows this
cardiologist
and then they find a product then in
like you know the heart health
space you know maybe it's a vitamin and
they go
and um get that doctor and they joint
venture with the doctor and they build
the infrastructure to sell the product
and do the customer service and build
the freight formula
maybe they buy an existing cardiology
product that's already out there
and they use this this famous brand and
then they you know spend a bunch of
money on facebook and build that brand
even further
and you know they've absolutely killed
it with with this strategy
and you know they don't all work i think
they're they're almost like an incubator
you know some of them fail but
uh but the formula works and so i think
a lot of people could i mean obviously
you see the kardashians do this like you
know
anybody who's got a brand i think um
could play in the you know the ecom
space which of course is
you're basically growing in the behind
amazon you know as amazon helps you know
just
expand the e-commerce universe there's
kind of this wind in your cells from
from all the amazing work that they're
doing and shopify is doing so
i think a lot of people could take
advantage of that for sure
uh whole foods is a uh a pretty
interesting one what are your thoughts
there
well this is my silliest one but i uh
i've always wanted someone to create
this like
i love what walt disney did with um with
his brand
i mean it's just insane if you look back
at what walt disney did
it's just so inspiring uh to take a
cartoon brand
and think i'm gonna go buy thousands of
acres you know near los
angeles and then you know eventually in
florida and build a theme park
um and i think disney's a great example
of all these things they bought
companies they
they spawn up other brands they leverage
their brands all kinds of different
things cruise lines you know etc
so whole foods you know everyone trusts
whole foods is like this amazing
culinary brand right
i think they can build culinary world
where it's basically like a theme park
again postcode
but you know a theme park where you know
imagine the ad like
you know come see how you know 50 000
different kinds of food products and how
they're made and experience this place
and
i think it could be a huge tourist
destination the company that owns
italy created kind of a theme park in
italy that
you know most americans aren't as
familiar with
and it's like this really cool
experiential theme park where there's
just you know tons of tour buses showing
up every day
with tourists who want to go see you
know how yeah how is mozzarella made and
you know where where does you know how
is beer brewed
and so you can imagine like a huge theme
park like that maybe they put it in
orlando or outside of vegas where
there's already a lot of traffic
uh and making this an awesome culinary
experience and i i think whole foods
just
got the brand to do it i think other
food brands could do it too
um you know i also you know i love the
newsletter business
i i think they could also build a
premium newsletter about nutrition
and just you know own that category and
every time you're you know checking out
you know they give you a free
subscription and get you kind of you
know into the brand and then
upsell you into paying them you know
whatever it is 50 10 to 50 bucks a month
and uh if you want to get nutritional
updates you know from there they could
do nutritional software
yeah it also feels like uh maybe amazon
is playing this game of like vertical
integration they just came out with a
wearable
uh in the last couple days that uh it's
gonna track your health and fitness and
all this kind of stuff and like
i mean it's not hard for them to
immediately now start to hook that in
with what food you should order and then
through amazon prime it gets delivered
like you just start to put all the
pieces together it almost feels like
some of the larger companies are doing
this
does that take away the opportunity for
smaller companies or is that just a sign
that like
there's so much opportunity that you
know whether you're large or
small uh it's kind of a green field i i
think there's just so much opportunity
uh and yeah i think yeah but i think
these are great companies to learn from
their case studies are
are incredible um and especially we're
lucky that they're public and we can see
you know a fair bit of their numbers and
see kind of big behind the
scenes and see what they're doing uh but
you know you're so right there's this
you know there's this ecosystem effect
as you build out more products
um you know apple is probably one of the
greatest examples of this where you get
people
he kind of hooks on the services they're
hooked on the physical product
and so you know there's this huge moat
that you're building
you know buffett says you know buy moats
don't buy companies like
you know apple has got this amazing mode
amazon has this incredible moat
you know salesforce is doing the same
thing they're buying all the companies
that they can kind of
channel right through their software
right through their sales team and
on top of it they've got like i
mentioned the trade show and so you know
you turn to them for everything crm and
next thing you know
they launch customer service and you
know you're immediately gonna
look to them for that and so you know i
think oracle's done a great job of this
too
talk a little bit about starting a
company versus buying one i know you've
got some thoughts on um
acquisition and how that can be a great
jumping point
for for kind of kick-starting something
and then also increasing the odds of
success later
yeah i think there's a space that you
know it's so kind of unknown and
splintered
it doesn't even have a name that anyone
can agree on i started just calling it
micro private equity
um that i heard someone else say and you
know i
i think it's in a really interesting
space where i've been spending a lot of
my time recently
you know the there's all these companies
out there that are like three hundred
thousand
you know or i'll even say fifty thousand
of profit to two or three million
that for the most part the big pe shops
or even the mid market p shops they
really can't
spend their time on these they just
don't move the needle for a fund
um but they do move the needle for an
individual entrepreneur
who's trying to make you know half a
million a million a year two million a
year
and and and some of them can grow and
i've seen friends grow them to five to
ten million dollars a profit a year
and and the space is highly splintered
and if you can become good at sourcing
deals
it's the easy part is raising the
capital it's actually there's a lot of
capital
and plus the small business
administration lending
makes it very easy to borrow money um if
you're willing to personally guarantee
it you can leverage
up to i think 90 and take out a loan and
right now
uh you don't have to pay interest i
don't think for the first six months
and so you know one nice thing about
buying companies instead of starting
them is you get the advantage of the
leverage
you know the power of leverage is is as
i know you know like it's enormous
um the returns that you can make on your
capital when you only have to put in you
know 10 to 20
of the equity and i think one thing
people a lot of people in the startup
world don't really understand is joint
venture waterfalls
um you know what is that explain that
explanation for people
yeah so instead of thinking like
pre-money post money
uh convertible note sort of startup
methods of raising capital
the private equity world and the real
estate world work in this concept of a
waterfall
so i put in 10 of the equity needed
my investors put in 90 after we each get
our money back
i get 10 of every dollar out they get 90
percent of every dollar out for the
first dollars out until
we each get 100 of our money that we put
in back into our pocket
then we each get maybe an eight percent
return on that money
and after we've gotten our eight percent
return and our money back
then i as the entrepreneur who did all
the work found the deal put it together
worked in the company day to day
i then get a kicker i get a sweetener
maybe it's 20
somewhere between probably 20 to 50
extra percentage of every remaining
dollar of that business
so if you buy a company and you hold it
for 10 years
you know and and you buy it for the you
know four times multiple
in the first you know three to five
years depending on how much you grow the
company might even only be two years
you'll get everyone's capital back and
then for the next
you know five ten years you might own
fifty percent of that business even
though you only put in ten percent of
the equity
and so you're clipping 50 percent of the
profit plus you're paying yourself a
salary
and if you're if you're clever or
ambitious about this you can do this
you know you could use a few times a
year you could buy a handful of
companies and build a portfolio
spread the risk of you and your
investors across multiple companies
and uh you know you could bottle and you
could even put that all that into a
holding company which then has
you know enterprise value across all of
these things you could take the holding
company public
so anyway there's a lot of things you
can there's a lot of things you can do
with structuring that but
and i'll say one other thing about this
is uh
there's this concept that there are the
largest generation in american history
are the baby boomers
and they're retiring right now right
like my parents are 73 years old now i'm
37
and i'm the first year of the
millennials i was born in 82 i think
maybe i'm the second year
so over the next um you know 10 years
tens of thousands of business owners who
are baby boomers are retiring
and if they're running a small business
many of them can't sell their business
to like a strategic or a pe shop because
their business is too small
and they really they need an operator to
take over the business
and private equity firms they don't want
to be operators so they're not going to
buy
a business and step in and run it so for
in order for these people to retire they
need an entrepreneur like us to come and
buy it from them
and so there's a ton of opportunities
now to buy these baby boomer businesses
and
the other benefit is a lot of these
boomers they didn't really understand
online marketing
so maybe they're running an hvac
business in ohio
and you know they've had kind of a
reputation with their customers for
years but they've got almost no presence
on facebook and so you can buy this
company which has a great reputation
great employees
maybe even has a bunch of good surveys
on yelp but they're not spending any
money on google adwords they're not
spending you're not investing in
facebook
and you can totally transform the market
so there's a lot of opportunity there
and i think it's an exciting space
talk a little bit about as you go out
you start looking at businesses that to
potentially acquire
what areas or industries do you think
are interesting
well i just mentioned one that's kind of
interesting that the home services
industry
you know buffett and monger they love
these kind of boring businesses that
you know aren't going to be disrupted
overnight by new technology
and um and are enduring um so yeah home
services you know companies that install
pools and fencing and roofing or do hvac
servicing
uh are interesting businesses now the
downside of these businesses is that
they you know the challenge is the
personnel you've got to take over and
maintain
personnel but the upside is you're not
you don't have platform risk you know if
you buy
like a e-commerce company on amazon you
know there's always a risk that amazon
will just come out their own competing
product or
you know a competitor from abroad will
undercut you on pricing because they
have cheaper labor and so
i you know part of me kind of likes
these boring offline businesses
um but then i also really like you know
there's a lot of great online businesses
uh there's there's a number of companies
right now rolling up kind of the
fba the fulfillment by amazon space or
the shopify e-commerce space
of course software has always been a
space that you know pe shops love
but don't have the energy to buy the
really small companies so if you can buy
small
software companies there's a couple of
interesting companies that are kind of
rolling that space up there
there's this publicly traded company
called constellation which is this
amazing software company it's kind of
like the
berkshire hathaway of software and i
think you could build a mini version of
that
um where you buy there's so many you
know small kind of micros they call them
micro sas
businesses out there um and you can buy
them and if you
if you can buy them when they're small
when they trade for
you know three to five times earnings
and and
scale them up to where they're a little
bit bigger they trade for more like
eight to 15 times
or if you can aggregate a handful of
them together and then your collective
ebitda
is you know as you approach five 10
million of ebitda
suddenly private equity firms want to
buy you and if you can get above 10 you
can potentially even go public
so there's a multiple arbitrage
opportunity there where you're buying
low multiple and scaling it into a
higher multiple category so
yeah those are those are some ones i've
been i've been kind of tinkering around
looking at
how do you think about talent in these
businesses so businesses that maybe
are a little bit more antiquated they
haven't gotten
kind of updated with technology use of
the internet
um traditionally a lot of that's uh in
my experience been
uh the skill sets are different right so
people kind of do what they know
and if uh you bring a bunch of young
people in who are super
sappy with the internet and technology
like they start trying to put technology
everywhere right and do things
differently
if you don't have people who are kind of
up to curve
on certain types of technologies they
just don't know what they don't know and
so therefore they kind of do it the way
that they were taught or that they've
done
for their career so how do you think
about talent and kind of
managing existing talent when you're
going to buy a business versus um kind
of bringing in folks who
have different skill sets yeah in my
experience you you have to enter with a
lot of humility
and if you're going to buy a business
you got to come in and spend the first
six months just earning trust
and and leaving a lot of the things the
way that they're doing it
the same and making only a few strategic
changes so like
if you bought an hvac business you could
update the marketing right away because
the the the people you have out in the
field a lot of times in hack they get
paid
in part on commission for how many
installations they make or how much they
service and so
they definitely want more business so if
you could start by helping
the people that you're employing win
more business and earn more money
as opposed to immediately starting
changing with like how they implement
the business and how much data they need
to enter day to day the things that are
going to annoy them
about your new management style so i
would start with like you know how can
you actually help them earn more
and gain gain some of their trust and
then once they're kind of bought into
the new
this this a little bit of this new
method you say hey by the way we're also
now going to put in this new system
where you have to enter some more data
about you know what happened on the
visit and how many hours did it take you
to install the thing so that we can get
better at
you know optimizing you know how we put
you know labor out into the field in
this example so
i think it's like kind of like a
step-by-step you know kind of gradual
approach but
and i think you know one challenge if
you're gonna buy a portfolio it's like
how do you scale yourself you're not
gonna be able to be intimately involved
in every detail
and i think that's one of the amazing
things when i watch like buffett like
it's incredible how much you know they
don't meddle in the businesses and so
um you know one method is to be more
hands-off and be more of a capital
allocator and buy
things and you know leave management in
place or hire a gm
while you're under under loi to come in
and manage that business for you
and just provide them the right
incentives and culture which is
a lot easier said than done i'm like
amazed when i'm when i see how you know
some of these companies like
constellation have done that um
but yeah i think it's an i think it's a
challenge and an opportunity around
around the human element of this got it
and what do you think is the um the
counter argument right so
obviously there's a ton of opportunity
there's a ton of positives uh
to taking the approaches that that we've
talked about whether it's bootstrapping
or acquiring businesses and scaling them
what's kind of the counter argument that
people should be aware of or um you know
the downsides and obstacles well
look for for for society we
venture is amazing what it's done for
you know
the the human race if you will right
like you're not going to put rockets
into outer space
and solve uh you know major challenges
globally
without building billion dollar unicorn
companies
and so i i think you know just for
societal
reasons alone we need people that are
you know building massive companies like
like you know like a whole foods like an
amazon um you know like a spacex or a
tesla that can deliver these new
solutions and make huge
innovative breakthroughs um you know
especially think about just like what's
happened
in developing drugs you know you're not
going to develop a breakthrough for
covid
without spending you know hundreds of
millions or billions of dollars so
uh there's definitely a need for it
societally and then also some
entrepreneurs they
they want the adventure they want the
challenge they want the moonshot
of going and taking on a huge world
challenge and solving it
um and i think that's inspiring you know
i definitely
you know i watch you know some of the
people who have done this
and just blown away by the things that
they're doing um you know for me i'm i
think i'm like too timid i'm too
worried about failure failing and and uh
and having that financial anxiety that
we mentioned earlier
um and so part that's one reason that i
kind of avoid this personally
um and uh but yeah i think i think
that's that's one thing
is just certain certain concepts are
going to take a lot of capital
for sure and i guess as you kind of go
through this how do you
suggest people getting in touch with you
mentioned earlier like joint ventures
and ways to get access to capital
through private equity firms and stuff
like that
like what what's in your opinion some of
the things that people
should um should think through uh
and should um kind of be aware of as
they approach those conversations
uh in order to make it a win-win and
really align incentives
well i think that uh there's tons of
capital out there chasing deals and the
thing that's
in short supply are operators and deals
you know and you know fairly valued
deals
and so if you can bring uh yourself as a
good operator
and if you can bring a deal then you've
really solved like a major challenge for
investors who are trying to diversify
and put out capital and so
you're going to be in a really nice
position like you'll you'll be able to
get
pretty good terms today at least you
know it's kind of like a it's an
operators and kind of like a market you
know there's an opportunity to
structure deals that are pretty
favorable to the operator but
you know i think you know you really
want to make it a win-win you want to
earn a good reputation so you can keep
doing deals with your investors
um and so yeah i mentioned that joint
venture waterfall concept i think that's
a really nice way
of raising capital because i mean think
about the proposition like instead of me
saying look i'm going to value this
new concept at 10 million this random
number you know 10 million bucks and you
guys are going to put in a million and
we're going to
give you 10 instead you can say look
put in a million and every dollar out
initially you sweep and you're going to
get the first million
and after you get your million i'm also
going to give you this nice return
so at a minimum like you're kind of
protected to make this percent return
and then
if things go well and i'm really you
know doing what i said i could do
then i get the extra twenty thirty forty
percent of the steel only there of the
of the remaining capital
thereafter so i i personally just love
that structure i learned it from the
real estate private equity world
it said this is super common this is how
like developers build
you know office buildings and apartment
building in hotels
as they raise the capital in this kind
of joint venture waterfall
um you know nothing wrong with the
venture sort of methodology pre-money
post money i just
it's i find that like the argument is
like a little bit harder to follow
because you kind of believe in this kind
of valuation it's kind of hard to
pencil absolutely and i guess as part of
this
um when you think of uh
kind of where the world is going the
pandemic the economic shock the
recession uh the stimulus the
quantitative easing like there's so much
complexity in the world and so many
moving parts
do you see that as a opportunity
or do you see that as a something to
kind of be very
cautious of and could potentially be a
negative
well i've certainly been cautious and
not uh you know taking
too many there's been a bunch of
companies i looked at buying since uh
since around february and i've been
kind of following like the buffets of
the world and kind of trying not to do
too many things and being disciplined
and kind of waiting for the right
opportunity because it was kind of hard
to see where this was all going to shake
out
and it's still hard to see and from from
where i sit
uh you know maybe we'll enter a
recession next year and
the business i buy will you know be be
down 30 40 50
and especially if you so one thing would
be to use less leverage
in an environment like this don't put
too much debt on the business and burden
it
raise a little extra capital at the
outset even if that means you dilute
yourself a little more
whether that's starting a company or
buying company so you've got some
working capital
sitting around and then if you have the
extra capital and
a little bit of extra and less leverage
now you're in a great position
you've got a company you've got some
extra capital and you can be
aggressive because you know this is a
great time to be hiring people in the
coming year
talent is going to be less expensive
really top talent that maybe you would
have hired they would have left you in
six months for another great job
you're going to be able to maintain for
longer you know we built our businesses
out of the recession in 08 and these
were some of the advantages that we that
were really helpful to us
the other thing was competition was kind
of distracted
so you know like biz now we kind of came
out under the radar
when there were these big companies that
were doing commercial real estate
publishing and events
and in like 0-809 they were so busy just
cutting costs and dealing with
challenges and raising capital to
survive
that they really weren't paying
attention to us coming in and eating
their lunch
and by the time they kind of woke up to
what we were doing you know we had a few
hundred thousand
subscribers and a team and a great
product and so it was
harder and harder to compete with us and
we we ended up going from like kind of
like
the underdogs to being kind of like the
giant in the space
so i think if you've got uh this is a
great time to take advantage of those
kinds of things
absolutely and so i guess um
[Music]
how do you find the opportunities right
like i think that's another piece to say
okay great you you convinced me this is
an awesome way to uh
uh to kind of um build a business i want
to go do this
uh where do i find them like how do you
normally uh
think through uh finding either
acquisition targets or or markets to go
looking
all right so i stole this from this
venture capitalist page craig who
said something pretty brilliant so
he talks about hunting trapping farming
and trading
and i think i was kind of doing this
naturally but once i started once you
got this framework into my mind
i've like tripled down on it so hunting
so hunting is cold outreach so you know
you can
network you can um and you can also just
do cold email campaigns and if you
really want to get super sophisticated
about it you can build a team in like
the philippines that does outreach and
you can scrape linkedin and there's a
lot of clever ways to use technology now
and software and outsourcing
to build a huge legion pipeline for
whatever niche
it is that you're trying to buy
companies or if you're trying to buy
real estate or any other asset for that
matter
okay and then second is trapping so
trapping is becoming known in a niche
and becoming kind of like like you are
like you're this you know known entity
um in a number of different business
verticals and so you know one way is to
speak on podcasts like this
you know one way i love is host an event
you know
again with covid you can do this over
zoom but
you know you'd be amazed how many people
just come together even if you're a
nobody initially
if you say hey i'm getting the founders
together of a bunch of uh newsletter
companies we're gonna have a zoom call
or we all share notes and so i do this
all the time whenever i enter a new
vertical
and i find tons of people will show up i
used to do it like in the back of a bar
and serve drinks in manhattan uh and
what the way i would do it is i would i
would have calls one-on-one with five or
six people that i might have called
outreach or gotten a couple of warm
introductions to
and once i had those five or six people
and i earned some trust with them i'd go
back to them and say
hey here's a list i created i just
emailed you you pull this up
here's 50 names i think you know i saw
you actually friends with them on
linkedin
would you mind introducing them to me so
i can invite them to this like event
that i'm going to host on zoom or
you know this bar and you'd be amazed
how people come together and then you
become
kind of like the mayor of this space you
get up and give the toast you make all
the introductions
and so that puts you kind of in the
center of the universe of deal
and then you let all those people know
hey i'm looking to buy companies and
this is what i'm up to
this is my pieces so that's happening
number three is farming
farming is basically just spreading love
like just helping lots of people i
especially love like helping lots of 20
something up and comers
who are you know are doing all kinds of
cool ambitious things
and who are in a particular industry
you're interested in maybe it's
newsletters for example again
just get to know all just go and help
them and uh and give them free
you know help and advice and eventually
that starts to plant seeds with a lot of
people that grow into trees and start to
bring you deals
and then finally trading going to other
people that are doing deals
and saying look you're looking for
software deals i'm looking for
information product deals
every time i see a software deal i'm
going to send it your way and every time
you see this kind of deal would you you
know would you mind sending it my way
and like you know again people people
love this so like you know just
yesterday i sent like a software company
to a guy who's rolling up software
companies and
you know maybe he'll never maybe he'll
never send me something or maybe a year
from now he will so
if you do that with you know 50 people
it kind of adds up
absolutely um co-founders
versus no co-founders you talked a
little bit about kind of capital
partners
but how do you think about this in terms
of is this a
solo route to take or is this something
that's done more in partnership
so i think that depends on on your on
the individual like
there's definitely you know getting a
business partner i think i
underestimated initially is like getting
a spouse
it's a major it's a major commitment and
uh and it's really hard to know up front
if your business partners are going to
be that's you know the three things like
you know you want them to be right you
want to be high energy
high intelligence and i i'm speaking
about intelligence broadly maybe they're
having major amazingly high eq and so
they're awesome in sales
or maybe a really good iq and so they're
really good with systems uh
and then third you want them to be high
integrity
and um the challenge is it's really hard
to know that until you work with
somebody you know you interview a bunch
of people you get to know them even even
friends
you start working with and you learn oh
they're actually a little lazier than i
thought or
you know or they're just not a good
match you know for my personality for
whatever reason
um i mean one good thing is you'll grow
a lot and trying to be a better partner
to your business partners and so you'll
have to develop empathy and
patience and things like that but so i
don't know it kind of depends i
i know there are days where i'm jealous
of the ted turners of the world who just
owned
you know all their business and had no
partners and there are other days i was
like thank god i got these partners like
i would have never made that
you know that sale or thought of that
you know great idea
so um but yeah i think to the extent i i
would say
you know naval ravicon talks about look
at the signals like
look at the actions of your partners
more than what they say especially when
you're choosing a partner
and you know it's really in the hard
times you're going to find out if your
partners are really who you thought they
were
when you're running out of money when
you're making capital calls when
you've got to fire someone who's really
hard to fire like are they
gonna show up and treat you the way and
are you gonna treat them like the way
that you you know kind of imagine that
it might go down
um so you can kind of look at the
signals from their past like look at
their actions as best you can and kind
of determine that but
um yeah and it can be amazingly fun
having partners too
like you know they just bring a lot of
it's fun to have someone at midnight to
call and
you know gripe about your day with or
you know it's just so you can be
cathartic so
uh i don't know it's a tough calling
partner
absolutely you uh you're
hyper productive uh in terms of you've
done a lot um
and before we go to wrap up with some
rapid fire questions talk a little bit
about some of the hacks that you have on
the productivity side
that you've learned over the years in
terms of really helping you focus on the
highest priority things
yeah so i think people spend way too
much time in their inbox
and so i'm constantly telling my team
don't worry about being inbox zero
like ignore your emails if you're gonna
read them you know like tim ferriss's
four hour work week you know said like
bunch them up and read them at
certain times a day um and scan them i
think people would be amazed how many
emails they don't reply to just get
resolved especially when you have a team
like
someone else just resolves it or if you
look back at your inbox
well one trick is look at your inbox
three weeks ago
like go back three weeks and look at the
things that were in there
and see like you know did they really
have to be answered or solved
a lot of times they're not urgent so one
trick for this
is whenever i'm done with a phone call
about a lot of calls all day
my first thing is not to check my email
my first thing is to check my to-do list
because the to-do list really can move
major action items forward that really
move the needle
whereas responding to an email like most
emails
don't really move the needle a ton um
whereas like you know
hiring the next person building that
next big system like those things could
really make a huge kind of like
they leverage your time i think if you
have a team
every minute you can spend investing in
your team
instead of getting your own to do's done
creates leverage
if i can get like you know a person like
three people on my team to understand
the way i think about negotiating a
contract
instead of me doing the next contract i
struggle a lot with
like my team and getting them to do this
you know as people become managers on my
team
they want to keep doing the things that
they were doing because it's it's going
to be they'll tell me it's oh it's
faster
you know the person i'm managing isn't
very good at doing this so it'll just be
a lot quicker if i get it done for them
and like you they have to like go and
invest in that person so that
you know six months from now they're
never doing another one of those
uh items again and they're now
innovating and doing the next item
um so i know that that's really been
hard for me to you know kind of get out
of my own way and do that sort of thing
um but yeah i would say
um in general sticking to your to-do
list let's see what other things
oh another thing that i found is if you
don't spend like one late night
a week or maybe for some people i'm i'm
a late person but maybe it's an early
riser
you got to get like an extra like three
four or five hours in sometime in the
week at
a minimum whether it's on the weekend
early in the morning or late at night to
kind of like get into the proactive
stuff
because it can you can very quickly just
be in reaction mode all week and be
super busy
and i find it i make so much more
progress if i put in like one extra
chunk of time where i'm like okay
that project i've been holding off on
i'm gonna do you know during this period
and then one last thing i'll say is do
the hardest thing on your to-do list
first
like when you wake up you know do the
thing you most hate doing
that you know get that out of the way at
least for me maybe not for everyone i i
find
that that's huge because i'll just avoid
it all day
and one other thing i do too is i'll set
an alarm for two around two or three p.m
in the
afternoon and i'll the night before i
make my top five list so the things i
really were going to move the needle the
next day
and when that alarm goes off i check
that list to see if i actually done this
and if i haven't
i'll cancel everything else that's
happening the next like two three hours
and just get those things done
um and that way every day i don't miss
you know because a lot of times
otherwise it's like oh
i'll snooze it the next day the next day
the next day next you know three weeks
go by and you still haven't gotten done
yeah it's um it's so funny how humans
all
uh do the same thing right like
everything you're describing people are
gonna be listening now that
yup i do that if i'm really
intellectually honest with myself i
absolutely do that
uh and it's being uh one uh aware of it
but also too intentional about
you know putting yourself in a position
to be better about it right
you don't have to be perfect 100 of the
time but just being in a position to be
better
and improve something can have a
significant impact
yeah totally oh one last one i really
like i i think this is from getting
things done the
this kind of famous book anything you
can do in under like two or three
minutes
just just do it right away um sometimes
this annoys people on my team because
i'll like
you know they'll bring up something and
i'll just like pause it like give me a
minute and get it done and
and then so it's it's not always great
if you're like in a team call or
something
but otherwise if someone sends you an
email and you think or you think it's
something
that's quick i would just get it out of
the way and if you can't you know if
it's longer than that
put it on a to-do list and have it you
know and have it organized into some
sort of pocket
um but yeah we're all you know we all
have like a lot of us have the same bad
habits and so
i'm always trying to kind of you know
fix those
before we get into the rapid fire to uh
to finish up uh where can we send people
to
connect with you find out more
information um
or or send you deals that they think
potentially would be interesting to you
yeah if you just go to ryanbigelman.com
my name
uh you know it's b-e-g-e-l-m-a-n
ryanbigelman.com and you can subscribe
there
and uh i'll occasionally send out some
insights or share some info
and uh and also if you have a deal
that's 300 000 a profit or more
that you think i could acquire would
love to know about that you can send me
you can find my email on my website and
you can also follow me on twitter
and uh i get two questions i asked
everybody and you could ask me one to
finish up
uh what is the most important book that
you've ever read
oh easily untethered soul by michael
singer
um you know the most useful thing i've
invested my
energy into the last 20 years have been
trying to become more mentally fit
and you know i think a lot of people
think it's just like buddhism and my
mind from this but
man there's like really hardcore very
real
gains that you can make from you know
the same way that federer and the doll
are just better than every other tennis
player it's largely the mental game
um is the same it seems to be applied to
business or your relationships
is you know becoming more patient more
focused um being able to
i i really like this if you get
frustrated with something
how quickly can you can you switch from
frustrated to being back
at peace and like serenity and
clear-headedness
and even like as a manager i
i have to have a lot of endurance for
decision making i'll sometimes go you
know
six calls in a row where i've got to
make a decision
um and i get tired and so like you can
build up mental
endurance um and so anyway michael
singer's book
is a great place to start it teaches you
about how to develop awareness
and awareness is this muscle memory that
you can use to see
patterns and make huge gains so i love
that book uh
yeah that would probably be that's my
number one right there untethered soul
i haven't heard of that i'm not gonna
read that one for sure uh aliens
believer or non-believer
well there i i definitely believe that
there is
uh advanced you know beings somewhere
out there in
the vastness of our universe i mean so
100 believe that there's alien um
you know life forms maybe it's simply
bacteria
but you know my guess is there's also
advanced life forms i think it would be
um kind of uh sophomoric not to not to
imagine that there's going to be you
know there's like something
like you know a million times the number
of grains of sand on earth in the milky
way alone
uh you know there's probably another
rock that's pretty close to a sun
that's got lifeforms now whether or not
they've visited our planet
if that's what you're asking as a whole
another matter
um you know i don't know it's fun to
think that they're out there and that
they're
hanging out you know one crazy thought
is maybe they're among us
right now and we just can't understand
them like
you know to walk through the amazon and
pass an ant
and you to imagine trying to explain to
that aunt hey we built the skyscraper
over here in manhattan
you wouldn't even be able to communicate
with them they might not even you know
be able to fully understand anything
about your presence
and so i think um when you think about
artificial intelligence
super ai like you know there could be a
you know we there it'd be advanced forms
that are just like living on a different
frequency than us or a different
multiverse that are
so what does it mean to actually visit
earth quote-unquote
is like i think in itself kind of
complex but yeah if you're talking about
like you know the ufo landing and like a
movie i
i don't know i'm gonna guess that hasn't
happened
i i've never thought of it as like what
if we're the aliens to the ants
right like that like that's uh i've had
a lot of people answer that question
i've never had anyone
present it that way that's pretty good
way uh way to think about it
yeah well there's this concept of
fermi's paradox which is like why
haven't we seen other advanced life
forms and
you know it could be for any number of
reasons maybe they always get wiped out
because they kill each other
um you know maybe they're just too far
away they can't reach us
but yeah one plausible concept is that
they're
um over you know they uploaded their
information into the into like the
server
and you know as they became advanced and
they
you know they're traveling through a
frequency that's you know
that we can't imagine in the same way
that we can't see radio signals
and you know they're among us in that
way or we're living in a virtual
reality that they created and you know
they're just outside of the video game
that we're in
that is awesome you could ask me one
question
to uh to finish up what one question do
you have for me
yeah well well one thing is what what
are one of the more interesting uh alien
responses that you've gotten
yours is definitely one of them um no i
think most people fall into two
categories either yes i believe the
universe is so fast like
that type of stuff uh another is i don't
believe that i've never seen them
and so show them to me and then i'll
believe it uh are kind of like the two
most common
but it's like heavily slanted like 90
percent believe
10 percent don't um i had an alien
researcher come on one time
and uh i'm sorry an ancient alien
researcher
and uh he had a whole uh theory as to uh
the extinction of the dinosaurs was
actually driven by
uh meteors that impacted the earth and
it caused you know a change in the
climate all that kind of stuff but
everyone thinks it was a meteor that
collided into the earth instead actually
it was
uh alien spacecraft and you know you can
imagine the uh
the conversation from there a guy named
bruce fenton
and uh that one was pretty wild you know
i i
uh jokingly told a friend later i should
have been drunk for that one so that uh
i could like really let my mind uh
you know go and explore all the
possibilities
yeah that's an interesting one i mean
there's you know there's a there's a
handful people who believe
that uh the younger driest period that
you know wiped out a bunch of
civilization
uh like about 11 000 years ago was
caused by
um like a solar flare-up that led to the
magnetic field
changing on earth and which the magnetic
field protects us from i guess from
solar winds and so that led to like huge
lightning storms and
um and so that could have like wiped out
you know they could have clouded the
earth for a long period and
you know allowed to drought and all
these all these interesting things
maybe an alien caused the sun just to
flare up 11 000 years ago in some form
they set off a nuclear bomb on the side
trust me bruce has probably thought
about it
awesome ryan listen uh anyone who wants
to get in contact with you
ryan b-e-g-l-e-l-m-a-n right
e l m a n dot com uh or they can find
you on twitter
um any last parting words there my
friend
dude i just uh i love watching i love
listening to your show and uh
and reading your newsletters so i i
really appreciate it i think uh
everyone should uh pay more and more
attention and also i've been watching on
youtube now
while i eat lunch and i love i love how
you're a multi-platform it's awesome
all right thank you so much we'll have
to do this again in the future all right
thanks
talk to you soon